un match pour se placer dans la première
partie du classement plaisir les clés
recevez Bois-Colombes les derniers du
classement à l'occasion de la cinquième
journée de Nationale 3 après un début de
match accroché aussi bien au niveau du
score que de l'engagement les Yvelinois
arrivent à creuser des cars le score à
la pose 14 à 10 pour les plaisirs
ont été un peu un peu dur pour nous on
le temps qu'on rentre dans le match le
temps qu'on s'adapte à leur défense et
puis après on a réagi en changeant de
système défensif et c'est là qu'on a
commencé à reprendre le dessus donc je
suis super satisfait de la manière dont
on a réagi sur le terrain à partir de là
à 7/8 je crois c'est là où on commence à
reprendre le dessus donc faut que ça
continue dans cet état d'esprit là et
c'est parfait pour cette première
mi-temps au retour des vestiaires le
club de plaisir les clés continuent à se
correr pour gérer son avance malgré un
petit passage à vide bois-colombe ne
reviendra pas dans le match score final
31 à 26 on a pris les trois points donc
c'est c'est important après moi je suis
perfectionniste donc je vais retenir les
10 minutes où on a pris l'eau on est à +
10 et on n'a pas le droit de laisser
espérer l'adversaire de le